The Joe Rogan Experience so how did it
come up uh that this was being labeled
by the government as potential
terrorists oh Lord oh man
um because when I read that I was like
this got to be a mistake like this has
got to be just a misinterpretation of
what what you guys are doing yeah I so I
will say this when I thought I was being
suppressed
and then people were like yeah but you
know it's just your analytics suck or
whatever I was like yeah that's probably
that you know I was being optimistic
about that
well when
Kyle seraphin the have you heard that
name he's the FBI agent who leaked
the documents of
militant violent extremists mves that
were determined by the FBI of being
people and groups of Interest
um I knew it was a reality this just
recently happened this was probably six
months ago this just got leaked
so let's back up like a couple years
when I started a group called American
contingency
the idea for that group was coming from
um the issues in chats remember Chaz
like that little [__] Community they
basically blocked off a city block in
Seattle yeah yeah a rapper
um did that and and the police told the
community
um I'm sorry the police told the police
chief told the police through an email
we will not respond to calls in and
around the area of Chas unless it's a
mass casualty event
so there were law-abiding citizens who
were getting affected by politics
you know coming down on law enforcement
officers and telling them not to do
their damn job
so when this kind of evolved
um I said I'm going to start a group
called American contingency where people
can depend on each other they could help
people help each other out so that kind
of manifested itself into a group a
forum and the FBI analyst that was doing
open source open source searches on
intelligence
discovered the group and determined that
we were extremist and labeled us so when
he did that he contacted Facebook the
FBI contacted all these social media
platforms my company account got shut
down from Shopify Shopify said
um you have 48 hours to get your
information and you're gone so a
multi-million dollar business gone no no
way to get it back no way to contest it
or fight it because I don't have
millions of dollars and a lawyer to
fight it 48 hours to offboard it and it
was gone
um the FBI also told Facebook Facebook
banned us on all the traffic American
contendency got banned and all the [__]
got shut down
um suppressed for years and thinking
like what the hell is going on
I had an Insider in Facebook who just
got laid off during The Meta laid off
he actually uh four months ago before he
got laid off
I said hey can you look into American
contingency
a community-based group a freaking group
of good Americans helping each other in
a time of Crisis natural man man-made
disasters
I said can you see if we can get our
account back now that this thing's
leaked and they've determined I'm not a
domestic terrorist they call me a white
supremacist they there's actually an
article on uh on a leftist um uh wrote
like a 20-page article on a leftist uh
uh organization it's like a DOT org USA
Today published it and when the national
media picked it up it spread like
wildfire and everything got deleted when
that happened I said hey is there a way
that we can maybe get our stuff back
because they're saying we acknowledge it
was a mistake
um these guys and this guy Mike Glover
is not a terrorist
he looked into it and got a response
from the India team from India
that was managing my account that said
we looked into it and he is a domestic
terrorist and we cannot free up this
account because he's been labeled a
domestic terrorist how that got
determined was likely from the FBI
telling everybody but it still exists
today I mean today still exists
today are listed as a domestic terrorist
a domestic on Facebook on which
translates to Instagram I am listed as a
domestic terrorist I have the screen
grab from the from that conversation
from Team India Ireland was managing my
account when it originally got deleted
they offered it to India which obviously
there's going to be cultural issues
there
I am still labeled a domestic terrorist
group with American contingency and
myself labeled that as well
when they do this do they have to point
to any one specific thing that you guys
are advocating like how can they just
say you're a domestic terrorist because
you're telling people how to travel from
Arizona to Canada and one tank of gas
and how you know to treat wounds and how
to deal with a one-on-one combat
situation like how what don't they have
to have one thing they can point to what
Mike Glover said this so this puts him
in that category there was some analysis
done
um from Kyle serifin who when he did
this he uh he screen grabbed some stuff
and it looks like it was just this
analyst said it
he was actually rebutted by some guys
that I know in the FBI likely Hoss's
rescue guys that I work with overseas
like good dudes I mean the FBI hostage
rescue teams are great guys but it was
likely
told and communicated through some kind
of agreement between Facebook and the
FBI where they say hey here's the
Blacklist and I can't prove this but
this is Kyle thinks the same thing
here's the Blacklist Blacklist all these
guys and all these organizations because
they're potentially extremists I mean
the three percenters the proud boys who
we are not any of those we are lumped up
in the same exact list as that and and
it said it said these guys have a low
History of Violence and I'm like what
the [__] is low History of Violence mean
like zero should be zero it's low but
it's zero
um and and we even had proof we had to
submit proof of January 6 that we
weren't involved at all in fact I went
out and said hey as a organization you
should be concerned about taking care of
your family defending your family taking
care of your family stay the [__] away
from Washington DC that is literally
what we put out still that wasn't enough
to get us off the list it's a lit that
you have to prove that you weren't
involved in January 6. how nutty is that
crazy instead of them showing hey you
were involved in January 6th you have to
go out of your way to show that you
weren't wear something like that could
be the case with every [__] event
that happens in the world
prove that you weren't here prove that
you weren't there well a lot of the guys
who were getting rolled up they did they
were doing assessments of CCTV cameras
and just using facial recognition to
identify dudes and just go roll them up
and
I never thought to ever go there because
I the whole thing was [__] dumb to me
but I'm like dude imagine if I showed up
with with a correlation of
um hey this guy's labeled a terrorist
he's on site [__] I'd be the commander
of terrorist I mean that's enough
Fidelity to get me lined out and go this
dude's in prison I mean that would have
been me with your background especially
since they've already decided to label
you yeah
that's it's just so nuts to me that you
have to prove that you weren't a part of
something
when there's no evidence that you were
like that the the burden being on you to
prove that you weren't there is so crazy
they the the guy who wrote this it's
googable but if you like if you probably
put in Mike Glover domestic terrorist a
couple articles will will launch they
had pictures of me and a whole bunch of
people in Heber City Utah where my
headquarters is at
in those pictures we were doing
community events raising money for
charity and they were calling um they
said like Green Beret teaching militia
all these different tactics dude it was
20 it was actually impressive writing it
looked like AI wrote the [__] like chat
uh that chat GPT wrote it because it was
so well structured that if you read it
and you didn't know who the [__] I was
you'd be like this dude's a terrorist
and dudes were blowing me up like guys
were hitting me up on Twitter they're
like oh this guy's a [__] terrorist
and I'm like I can't believe this is
happening like all I want to do is
I feel like I earned it you know I had
the 20 years of service if you ask me
that 10 years ago I'd say no I'm still
earning it I feel like I earned it I'm
an entrepreneur running a business
trying to live my best life and I want
to be left the [__] alone and now I'm
being labeled a domestic terrorist by
the same organizations I worked with and
for and no advocating whatsoever about
trying to overthrow the government or
attacking people or taking back your
rights or storming the capital nothing
zero all of it I've seen your [__] all
of it is about being prepared for
natural disasters for the grid going
down something happening where you have
to protect yourself or your family
that's it that's it and if anybody
learned anything during the pandemic
they should have learned that we have a
fairly fragile
civilization if the grid goes down if a
natural disaster happens if something
goes sideways look with a disease that
kills a very small amount of people shut
the entire country down and it wrecked
the economy and [__] up a lot of
people's lives and
we didn't learn from that we didn't
learn like hey you know maybe we should
have some food stored maybe we should
have some contingency plan maybe we
should have a full tank of gas always
when we park our car at night so we can
get out of town maybe we should have you
know Firearms or you know fishing poles
like [__] something maybe we should
have something the idea that that nobody
can look at that that people can't look
at that and go oh this isn't domestic
terrorism this is just smart this is
just being prepared for disaster this is
being prepared for worst case scenario
the idea that being prepared for a bad
case scenario makes you a terrorist is
[__] nuts that's that's really that's
really crazy yeah it was a kick in the
dick for sure I mean I and that it could
affect your business like that they
could shut you down yeah when they shut
me down my merchant service account at
the same time shut us down and you can't
fight that you can't say like what are
you talking about how are we a terrorist
no we we tried to rebutt it through
emails but they're like nah this [__]
We're Not Gonna you can't do it
um you could do it with millions of
dollars and a lot of litigation over the
course of time but you don't have the
ability to do it and we couldn't do it I
couldn't afford to do it and they don't
even have to have an example no no the
no recourse and it's still it's still
I mean as far as I know from four months
ago Facebook if like if you if you went
in and you tried to type in American
contingency.com into Facebook or
Instagram as an as a algorithm it
detects it and we'll shut it down they
delete my mom as an entrepreneur
um uh Korean immigrant uh well she's she
married my dad when she was
um one of my Devastation in the Army in
Korea brought her over started her
business from [__] from scratch like put
up put a one uh Chair salon in our
garage that was dirt garage put concrete
down and started that business from the
ground up worked 20 29 years at this
point building this business had a
Facebook account with a few thousand
followers in Fayetteville North Carolina
me was Beauty Salon and Spa
they deleted it they did the leader
account because she reposted something
um from that account saying somebody I'm
proud of my son and they deleted her
account because anybody who who uh
reposted the link immediately got their
[__] deleted with no explanation
completely deleted forever when did this
be come a narrative like when did being
prepared because you know they used to
have those prepper TV shows and a lot of
them just seemed paranoid and some of
them just seemed wise like that some of
them just seemed like hey probably a
good idea to have some food laying
around probably be a good idea to have a
plan in case anything goes bad well when
did it become a narrative that someone
who's preparing is a potential domestic
terrorist I think it's it was the onset
of
the covid
um when covet happened
we were talking about preparedness years
prior to this in November of 2019 after
watching Bill Gates documentary on
basically covet I think it was on
Netflix
and he was talking about pandemics and
all the potential for Mass catastrophe
and loss in human populations
we talked about it and it was a thing
like we said hey like these are things
you got to be prepared for look our
mission statement is we want you to be
best prepared we don't care what Walk of
Life you come from
being prepared needs to be inclusive I
hate that [__] word but it needs to
be inclusive because disaster is an
equal opportunist it doesn't give a [__]
who you are it doesn't care what race
what wealth bracket you come from it
will hand you your ass so our thing was
if you plan for the worst case scenario
by default you're covering everything in
between so yeah we use in in our
verbiage worst case scenarios but we're
not trying to be Doom and Gloom because
we're talking about practicalities my
guys teach self-defense uh 2019's the
last statistic 400 around 400 uh
Justified shootings according to
civilians not a high probability you're
going to be in a [__] gunfight but
you should learn to defend yourself and
your family with responsible Firearms
ownership and gun handling that that is
not extreme but when you sum it up and
you say we're preparedness company and
who owns the preparedness company a
former CIA bootlecker a [__] um a
Green Beret sniper whatever that the
narrative is then we fit the narrative
for them so you fit the the Bundy Ranch
sort of 100 English uh yeah yeah